you finding love over here
that's okay come on step over i thought
that might happen i'm wearing a ring
under this
i think it was too strong to get it off
oh yeah
open up thank you
my girlfriend says you know man
shouldn't wear jewelry
but i
disagree must have hurt yeah you think
after 30 years i'd be able to walk down
an icy driveway without falling on my
ass no i i meant the ink
you know i got a little mermaid tattoo
on my back and i almost cried when they
put it on a little mermaid yeah
though that must have been some party
well you know how it is miss bent youth
it was same here i guess
i'd like to um get a good look inside
before you close yeah sure yeah you're
all good to go
god bless
you everything okay sir
yeah
i can't read my own writing
um
thank you thanks statuary hall it's uh
upstairs to the left
excuse me hey sorry um there's supposed
to be a smithsonian event in there
nothing on the schedule
maybe got moved to another room i i'm
supposed to give a speech
i doubt it but don't let that stop you
i'm a real good listener
peter
nobody's here did i get the time wrong
no you follow directions perfectly know
which boats well
but the hall's locked there there's no
event
i'm sorry could you just put peter on
and peter is in you're off
i'm sorry what
the borderland between heaven and hell
yeah thank you i know what the auraf is
and whether he returns to your world or
moves on to the next will depend on your
actions
there exists within the city an ancient
portal
i know peter likes to be the center of
attention but
this is objectively extreme um peter if
you're listening honestly consider
medication for someone with so much
knowledge
you know so little
but that will change
and you will solve the great mystery
it looks so real and peter will point
the way
well where is he
as above
so below hello
hey okay we're clearing this area
phone's awake sir damn sir
keep it moving yeah thank you clearing
this out get these guys get these guys
away from here
please keep moving
thank you close up now clearing this out
thank you
sir
sir
i know these symbols
he's got peter
that's his ring
stay right there
you